hello everyone and welcome to a
beautiful miniature that was sent to me
by a subscriber uh playing with the
black pieces here Mr floppy Tuesday and
he's playing against a gentleman named
debuff and it was a chess.com game it
was a three minute Blitz game and uh
okay I do get a lot of games by
subscribers and they send me okay I uh
completely annihilated this guy I played
like morphe I played like tile style
here and maybe you want to check out
this game I rarely uh show the games as
um it's mostly something that we've
already seen but this game it's
incredibly short only nine moves and it
features a line I've never seen before
and I think you guys will benefit from
it because I've checked the leeches
database over 3 000 people some three
and a half thousand people uh fell for
this exact same trap so if you face the
Vienna a lot you might be able to get
something from this so let's check it
out uh Mr buffin
um or maybe Mrs buffin opens with a
Ponte E4 we have Ponte E5 Knight's the
C3 going for the Vienna the game and now
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to F4 so this
is the uh folk beer variation in the
Vienna Gambit uh the Gambit is basically
do you want to capture on on F4 and then
E5 can be played so it's a pretty tricky
line where you go back to G8 or you play
Queen D7 first then Queen D2 and then
you go Knight back to G8 all in all
white will get a lot for this uh most
likely temporary font sacrifice You'll
Play H4 Knight to a 3D for and so on all
very natural moves will be played so
instead Pawn to D5 this is the main line
of the Vienna game and now F captures an
E5 maybe not the first move that comes
to mind uh because you you want to keep
developing you know that by playing the
Kings game with the full b or the the
Vienna you you have to keep developing
but if captures and E5 comes with Tempo
so it's okay
you attack the Knight and F6 Knight
captures an E4 and now Queen to F3 so
just nicely developing you don't have to
worry about Queen Tage for check now uh
and here we have Knight the C6 Ponte F5
and Knight the C6 are the two main ideas
here uh Mr floppy Tuesday played Knight
to C6 and now uh usually uh you want to
play Bishop to B5 here this is the best
way to counter this Knight to C6 move
but in the game Knight captures and E4
was played a probably expecting captures
and captures But Here Comes Knight to D4
and okay this doesn't um uh yet lose the
game for white but white has to be
incredibly precise here you have to play
Queen to C3 and then after d captures an
E4 You're Gonna Play Knights to E2 okay
everything is nicely defended you don't
have to worry now you can either move uh
defend the Knight or remove the Knight
back Knight to C6 and the game continues
with uh okay it's a game but black has
nothing to worry about here however here
Queen to D3 was played instead of Queen
to C3 and okay yeah you might be
thinking he wants the uh capture on e4
but not really and interestingly over
three like I said over 3 000 games with
this queen to D3 move in the leeches
database uh D captures an E4 and now not
a recapturing because if you recapture
then Bishop to F5 again is completely
winning for black uh instead Queen to C3
was played but now comes the Shocker
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this uh most elusive idea uh while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting that
the White Queen is trapped and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Bishop to B4 this is what Mr
floppy Tuesday played uh and there is no
good way to counter this the problem is
if you capture the best of dangerous
Knight captures and see to check uh with
with a triple triple Royal Fork here the
king the rook and the queen so of course
that is completely losing and it doesn't
matter if you play any other moves in
the game Queen the C4 was played but now
comes an even greater shocker and that
is Bishop to E6 and he was in this
position on move 9 and then Mr buffin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here also uh interesting
that it's buffing when there is a muffin
on his profile photo so um maybe you
guys can make something out of that but
yeah a very interesting stuff here so
the queen is attacked there is no Square
where you can move the queen okay you
can maybe prolong the game a little bit
you could play uh no there's really no
no square you could play some silly
moves and then drag the game on but
there is no reason to do this and the
point is uh that okay white played a
hundred percent accuracy game I've seen
the 99.6 I've seen 99.7 but this is 100
um a percent accuracy as uh it's only
nine moves uh five of the moves are book
moves that of course the engine always
gives a 100 accuracy two of them were
excellent moves and two of them were
brilliant moves so Bishop to B4 uh
attacking the queen and Bishop T6
attacking the queen uh the the chess.com
engine deems both moves uh brilliant
moves so there you have it uh Mr buffin
and and uh for Australian floppy 4p
Tuesday uh uh were able to uh to create
this masterpiece where uh one of the
players played a 100 accuracy game I've
never seen that uh I know I'm guessing
it's fairly rare but uh it comes from a
line that like I said over three and a
half thousand games so if you guys say
it's the Vienna a lot you definitely
need to know this so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed a bit of a
short one but we've covered a long
tournament so I thought maybe we'd take
take a breeder you know with a with a
nice fun game so thank you Mr poppy
Tuesday for for sending this to me and
you know uh best of luck in future games
I wish you a more uh even more 100
accuracy games yeah really hope you
enjoyed it try to use it if you can I
would like to thank David Kimura David
gasparian Ricky Johnson father and Derek
King for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up everything that's
happening in the Chess World and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day